hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 82 of game
programming so last time we took we
talked about collision and very very
precise division in our level class over
here an actual actually working on
collision mathematically rather than
aesthetically and today we're basically
going to implement this collision in our
particle class to enable particles to
bounce off walls and to basically not go
into walls so the first thing I want to
do is adjust this random longnecks float
that's what it's set to I'm sorry on
that there's XA stuff that's set to
basically go right I'm just gonna get
rid of this so this entire this subjects
a is less than 0 and up to this next
course and essentially I'm just gonna
replace that with a semicolon and what
that will do is of course I allow our
particles to go omnidirectional
basically in any direction okay so once
we've done that we're pretty much ready
to roll so the deal here is that um the
deal here is that you can say that
they're kind of going to the walls in
fact it looks like the center here isn't
actually in the wall it looks like it's
um I mean it looks like the center is in
the wall nice well because of this minus
12 here let's just get rid of that for
now and that should render them pretty
much at the tip as you can see right
there and we can adjust this later again
this is just really really minor
rendering offsets to make it look nice
but over here what we've got is the
translation right so every update our x
y&z coordinates actually al z XY and z
positions of the particles moved by this
much okay by X a Y and Zed a
respectively
now we want to kind of change that and
say well yeah cool like move like that
but if there is a collision you actually
have to just change direction okay and
the way we're gonna do that is by making
pretty much the same collision or the
same move method that we have in our
MOPP class which is over here you know
move and if there's a collision if
there's no collision move otherwise do
something else okay so um that's how
it's gonna work now because we're not
doing a because we don't want to stop
the particles
moving it there's a collision so what
this code says right here is that if
there is if there is no collision move
the particles if there is a collision
well dart okay
just continue past this if statement
over here we still want to move them we
just want to flip their flip that
direction and that's kind of the same
deal that we did here with the floor
right to make them bounce we multiplied
it we multiplied Z a by a negative
number and we also made it less than 1
to slow them down
so that essentially the particles would
reverse their direction as well as slow
down so that's the idea that we're going
to employ for this for this sum method
as well so first thing we're gonna need
is a move method okay so it's gonna
basically take two parameters
essentially the XX and the YY and says
that because of course y&z of the same
since this is a dirty game so xx + X a
so that's where it's moving to and YY
plus in fact let's put this in brackets
just so it's more readable y y + y a + z
z + set a okay and this is all one
equation of course so this is exactly
the same thing that we did with the
where is it was it projectile right
where we check for tile collision but we
actually added these right over here in
the parameter because we don't need them
separate in the actual method so now
let's create this method so we'll just
mouse over it a great method it'll
create a move method for us with the
parameters already in set so let's say
so we'll change this to X and this to Y
and now we can actually start scared of
this now it actually starts doing the
collision I'm sorry the move method so
what we want to do first of all is move
these down here whoops and I'm just
hitting alt and then the up and down
arrow keys that actually moves the
selected line or wherever you want this
uz so that's fine but now we have to
also check for collision so that's where
the collision method comes in now I'm
going to go to level class and pretty
much just copy and paste this tile
collision method into this particle that
Java class okay here it is I'm gonna
change it to just speak collision it's
still gonna be a boolean but these frame
is also going to change around a bit we
know the size of particles we don't need
that and we don't need offsets will hawk
code that pretty much because we don't
need the mask parameters okay in fact I
probably won't be any offsets because
these particles are exactly the right
size they're not offset because they're
not gonna sprite they're um they're
actually centered they are there this
bright that they are in is the size of
the particle
so no offsets are required okay cool so
let's try some of this stuff out first
of all we'll change the size to be 16
which is the size of our tiles and
everything else is pretty much fine here
in fact we'll probably change these
integers to be doubles okay cool so
that's looking pretty good now because
we change to double that changes to
double as well and of course we can't
use bitwise operations on doubles so we
do have to change this back so you
divide it by 16 Oh
kyoool now because the get tile method
does require integers we have to also
make a an integer here which is
basically going to be a cast of a double
which in this case is XT and
the same thing for YT and what I'm gonna
do is I'm probably gonna round it down
it probably will be rounded down anyway
but I'm gonna put math don't actually
want to round it up so math dogs seal
and what this does is it rounds the
number up and set it down okay because
by default if you can if you call
something to an integer and it's a
double it just make sure we changes to Y
it just um all it does is pretty much
chops off the decimal points so if you
have four point eight or four point
seven it just cuts that off and gives
you four what we want to do is what we
essentially do by a calling math dot
seal is we change the four point seven
to a 5.0 and then of course when we
calls to an integer just chops that off
and we get around a number a number
that's rounded up which is what we want
for now anyway I'll demonstrate this in
a minute and then of course will change
the sceptile things to be
and I wine and that should give us the
right tile and if it is okay time to
find for particle make sure we change
this to level dot guitar course and that
should be pretty good that's actually
all we need for now
so this is our um a particle thing our
collision detection for our particles
for now okay it's not exactly correct
but I want to show you guys what this
will look like so now what we want to
say is if there is a collision anywhere
basically at xx plus XA and then the
same p.m. patterns gonna copy and paste
this in fact we probably don't need to
do that do we because we pretty much do
that anyway so I think x and y will
pretty much work because we're
referencing these ones which are the
correct ones so if there's a collision
we're going to reverse every direction
so this XA whoops this XA x equals we'll
start with negative 0.5 right and we'll
see what that looks like so we'll do the
same for Z and Y okay and that what that
will do is we if we plot this bracket in
what that will do is reverse the
direction of our particles if there's a
collision so let's test this out and see
what it looks like all right so first of
all you can say that our particles that
indeed not going into the wall here and
but we do have problems here as you can
see but first and foremost so in the
wire we've got a few issues and if we go
up we probably have issues in the UM in
a negative y-direction as well okay we
don't but yeah you can say that
absolutely none of these particles are
going into the wall so that's a start
but you can see that over here we've got
a problem
and if we should download that problem
let's try and find a better spot here
okay so push you down we've got a
problem if we should left or right is it
right we have a problem
okay so and the reason for that is
because of rounding okay honestly so you
can see right now if I should yeah
actually let's find out what do we spawn
do the thing is we spawn in a really bad
place to know I might want to change
that okay so if we shoot right you can
see we've got an error here because what
happens is the occlusion that is
actually picked up here is inside the
wall already and that's a problem now
that's because we're rounding
up now if we do round down by hitting
out math doll floor instead you can see
that if I move over to the right look at
that our particles are beautiful they're
fine
okay so but now that we've rounded down
if I go to the left side up we've got
the problem here so what happens is
we've only got the problem in session in
certain situations now that's fine we
can handle this with a simple if
statement what we can do is we will set
math we'll set all these equal to
ceiling by default but what we'll say is
if see mod 2 is equal to 0 and remember
say mod 2 is equal to 0 when we're
checking for the left side then let's
make math sorry let's make IX equal
again the int cost of math dot floor
this time of X T ok let's see what this
looks like so what this will do is
actually is if collisions being picked
up here it'll use math dot floor
but if collisions being picked up on the
left side it will use metal seal and as
you can see what we get here is a pretty
damn good collision detection now we
have to do the same thing for y of
course because if you recall if you
recall we do have a problem over here as
well if we should downloads which is
kind of publishing just going down
should I push you downloads we get this
so let's change let's pretty much copy
and paste this entire if statement here
and say that if Z divided by 2 is equal
to 0 then let's change by Y to mouth or
floor and of course of YT ok simple as
that
now let's run this let's go down this
time so there you go
and if we shoot in two corners or
whatever you can see that our particles
don't go in the corners now there are a
few um what do you call well you can see
that if we shoot down there's just a bit
of offset here in rendering so what we
might want to do is maybe subtract one
from it which will move it up by one
pixel just from the Y here so we're at
we're at we're in we're rendering the UM
the particles just one pixel buffer you
can say that probably looks a bit better
we might even want to go two pixels oh
that might be too much
yeah okay so that's been pretty good and
you can see that if we go around here
everything is awesome now one thing I
want to do just to demonstrate that's a
bit better it's probably going to our
hidden wizard with a projectile that we
create these yeah and I'll save their
life to 440 just so we can see this
collision a bit better so if they move
around which they don't let's set the X
for example sorry back into um particle
let's set the X to just be pretty much
1.0 so in other words someone actually
let's just comment that line out CBS
doesn't decrease in velocity so yeah you
can see right there had there bouncing
off each other in fact probably be
better if I do change
was it projectile to be 44 instead of
444 the life so yeah what we can say
here is you consider they're bouncing
off okay which is really cool I'm not
digging there's life and now with it
projectile maybe like 144 on oh yeah and
he considered that bounty oh this is a
good example see that they're bouncing
off and none of them are going into the
walls which is awesome now there's
probably a bit of an X it's really cool
because they're getting they're not
decreasing in velocity on the x axis
they just sort of going here how they're
always reaching it hanging all nice
changes 240 400 again that was cool yeah
so you can see that they're not
increasing in velocity and there they go
bouncing off again so that's very very
cool I really like that effect but one
thing we should probably do is just
offset our particle on X by like one
pixel as well
whoops I press that twice let's just
launch that again
I think that'll look a bit better
especially over here yeah it's pretty
solid so that's how that rolls let's
uncomment this line and see what our
actual particle simulation looks like
and you can see that's very very cool
because we've pretty much got
physics implemented right now okay so
that is gonna wrap up this episode this
is true particle physics here with
proper collision you can see in pretty
much every direction that looks awesome
I'll probably will change this back to a
minus one though just because it doesn't
look 100% killed over here and okay
there we go I was beautiful
what you might want to do as well it's
offset it a bit higher because you can
say that our King Cherno here actually
goes up over the over the over the wall
assume I want to change them or you
might want to play around with it
but I think this looks really nice um
we're probably gonna cave it at this
form for the game so this could be used
for blood that this could be used for
you know stone crumbling as you can see
here there's a there's just so many uses
for this so it is very useful to know
how to do this of course and well yeah
okay so next episode the next few
episodes we are going to look at sprites
and how to make them essentially in
After Effects because like not probably
about 19 out of 20 of you wanted to see
me make sprites in front of you guys so
show it on video so that's what I will
be doing so the next few episodes are
probably gonna be just sprites so if
you're not interested in that that's
fine just don't watch the video you know
but other than that guy's place hit a
like button if we hit 200 likes I'm
gonna release these sprite videos twice
as fast yeah that means like two videos
a day possibly but I need 200 likes for
that so make sure you hit that like
button and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
you